you should have movie with Al Pacino and
I have to ask you about that because he
is maybe one of my top maybe two actors
of all time was it exciting to work
without Gino it was he like he I mean
everyone I'm sure knows and has many Al
Pacino stories but he's one of my
favorite people he was my one of my
favorite people before shooting the
movie but then after she kind of reminds
me a lot of my dad in a weird way and
but there was we were shooting in
Atlanta and there's a strip club called
the Clermont guys you know I had never
been there they have looked over here
you know and and I told I told Al I was
like I want to take you to a strip club
because that would I would die a happy
person if I could take opportunity to a
strip club and he said that he had never
been to one and I said Al Pacino you've
never been to a strip club and he said
honey the strippers have always come to
me and I said he was joking yeah I think
yeah but I don't know let's assume he
was joke it's really sad to have
strippers come back that he was I think
he was kidding yeah
you